>>> NOW, LOOK.
THIS IS HOW REPUBLICAN SENATOR
MARSHA BLACKBURN OF TENNESSEE
QUESTIONED ONE OF PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S JUDICIAL NOMINEES TODAY.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> ON THE EVE OF THIS HEARING,
IT HAS BEEN MADE PUBLIC THAT HE
HAS A RAP SHEET WITH A LAUNDRY
LIST OF CITATIONS INCLUDING
MULTIPLE FAILURES TO APPEAR IN
COURT IN TENNESSEE.
WE EXPECT OUR JUDGES TO RESPECT
THE LAW, NOT DISREGARD IT.
IF MR. MATHIS THOUGHT THAT HE
WAS ABOVE THE LAW BEFORE,
IMAGINE HOW HE'LL CONDUCT
HIMSELF IF HE'S CONFIRMED AS A
FEDERAL JUDGE.
>> RAP SHEET?
I MEAN, IF YOU'RE LIKE ME AND
YOU HEARD HER SAY THAT YOU MIGHT
BE THINKING, WHAT DID THIS MAN
DO?
SO LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT HIS --
WAS THE WORD "RAP SHEET" HE
USED?
HE APPARENTLY FORGOT TO PAY FOR
THREE SPEEDING TICKETS OVER TEN
YEARS AGO.
ONE, BRACE YOURSELF, ONE WAS FOR
GOING FIVE MILES OVER THE SPEED
LIMIT.
AND BY THE WAY, MATHIS, THE MAN
YOU SEE HERE, HE'S FROM
TENNESSEE, THE STATE THAT
BLACKBURN REPRESENTS.
AND LISTEN TO HOW HE HAD TO
RESPOND.
>> I HIGHLY REGRET THAT I'M IN
THIS SITUATION.
I FEEL LIKE I'VE EMBARRASSED MY
FAMILY.
I TRULY REGRET THAT.
I DESERVE THIS.
THEY DON'T.
I CAN ASSURE THE COMMITTEE THAT
I'M A LAW-ABIDING CITIZEN.
I'VE NEVER BEEN ARRESTED.
I'VE NEVER BEEN CHARGED WITH A
CRIME.
>> YOU SHOULDN'T BE EMBARRASSED
OR REGRET.
I MEAN, HE'S NOT THE ONE WHO
SHOULD BE EMBARRASSED ABOUT THE
WAY YOU HANDLED THIS SITUATION.
AND I WANT TO BRING IN NOW THE
FORMER NAACP PRESIDENT AND CEO,
CORNELL WILLIAM BROOKS, BECAUSE
I CAN IMAGINE, CORNELL, I CAN
ALMOST PREDICT WHAT YOUR
REACTION WAS, I ALMOST CALLED
YOU TO BE LIKE, DID YOU SEE THIS
JUST NOW?
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
UNBELIEVABLE.
>> UNBELIEVABLE.
IT WAS EXTRAORDINARILY PAINFUL
TO WATCH AS AN AMERICAN AND AS
AN AFRICAN AMERICAN AND
CERTAINLY AS A BLACK MAN.
WHY?
BECAUSE HERE WE HAVE THE FIRST
WOMAN ELECTED TO THE UNITED
STATES SENATE FROM THE STATE OF
TENNESSEE HUMILIATING,
DENIGRATING, DEMEANING A BLACK
MAN WHO HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE
THE FIRST BLACK MAN TO SERVE ON
THE U.S. COURT OF APPEALS FOR
THE SIXTH CIRCUIT.
SHE REFERS TO LESS THAN A
HANDFUL OF SPEEDING TICKETS AS A
RAP SHEET.
NOW, YOU KNOW, LAURA, ONE OUT OF
EVERY THREE AMERICAN ADULTS HAS
A CRIMINAL RECORD.
THAT IS TO SAY, A RECORD OF
ARREST.
77 MILLION PEOPLE.
>> HE'S NOT ONE OF THEM.
>> HE'S NOT ONE OF THEM, THAT'S
EXACTLY IT.
THAT IS EXACTLY IT.
AND SO WE KNOW THAT THIS
INVOKING OF A RAP SHEET INVOKES
AN UGLY HISTORY OF CRIMINALIZING
AND STEREOTYPING AND DEGRADING
BLACK PEOPLE.
SO IN THE CONTEXT OF A JUDICIAL
NOMINATION HEARING, HE IS
SURROUNDED BY HIS FAMILY.
AND LITERALLY HE IS HUMILIATED,
ALMOST REDUCED TO TEARS, IN
FRONT OF HIS CHILDREN.
THIS IS CONDUCT UNBECOMING OF A
UNITED STATES SENATOR, AND
SURPRISING FROM A WOMAN.
>> CORNELL, YOU KNOW WHAT, I
COULDN'T HELP BUT THINK, IN THE
RECENT THOUGHTS ABOUT HOW
JUDICIAL NOMINEES HAVE BEEN
HANDLED, GOSH, I WONDER HOW THIS
SAME SENATOR MAY HAVE ACTED WHEN
SOMEBODY WAS ACCUSED OF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT WHO WAS A NOMINEE FOR
THE SUPREME COURT.
SURELY A STATEMENT THAT SHE MADE
AND THE IDEAS OF WHAT WE EXPECT
ABOUT ABOVE THE LAW AND THESE
NOTIONS ABOUT YEARS-AGO BEHAVIOR
THAT ARE ALLEGED, I ASSUME SHE
HAD THE SAME ONES.
INSTEAD, DO WE HAVE THE CLIP
WHAT HAVE SHE ACTUALLY SAID
ABOUT NOW JUSTICE KAVANAUGH?
BECAUSE I WANT TO PLAY IT.
LET'S PLAY IT.
>> WE HAVE SPENT ENOUGH TIME AND
MONEY TRASHING A GOOD MAN AND
HIS NAME.
HE IS ON THE SUPREME COURT,
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH IS AN
HONORABLE MAN.
HE IS DOING AN HONORABLE JOB ON
THE SUPREME COURT.
>> BUT CORNELL, DID HE SPEED?
DID HE EVER SPEED?
BECAUSE THAT WOULD MAKE HIM
DISHONORABLE AND SOMEBODY WHO,
IMAGINE IF HE WERE ON THE COURT.
THAT STRIKES ME AS QUITE A
DICHOTOMY EVEN THOUGH THE
ALLEGATIONS ARE OBVIOUSLY QUITE
DISTINCT.
>> IT'S A DICHOTOMY BUT IT'S
ALSO RANK HYPOCRISY.
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH WAS MY CLASS
MATE AT YALE LAW SCHOOL.
I EXPECTED HIM TO BE QUESTIONED
FAIRLY IN THE SAME WAY I
EXPECTED THIS JUDICIAL NOMINEE,
ATTORNEY MATHIS, TO BE
QUESTIONED FAIRLY.
BUT TO SUGGEST THAT HE WAS
SOMEHOW A FELON, SOMEHOW A
NE'ER-DO-WELL, COME ON.
LET'S BE FAIR.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS HAVE
SPEEDING TICKETS.
THIS